welcome back to the edge with your boy
Michael Parson live in your Bleacher
Report app as always drop your comments
and questions in the chat and I'll be
looking through them throughout the show
let obviously the big loss against the
Dolphins on Christmas Eve obviously a
great game uh well contested game I
thought it was a great game overall
finally got against go against my man
Tyreek for the second time in my career
always fun um great battle between
obviously between Tua having Tua tyreq
Duo um prayers up the Wadd um you know
we don't know what's going over there
but you know he went out early but
obviously extremely fun game um
obviously there was a lot that we can
learn from this um obviously we did way
better in the Run game we did we we just
you know it just came down to one or two
plays that could change the game even
one that I wish I could take back was
the ring the passer on that third and
one uh and I believe we could have got a
stop and head him to a field goal and
that could have changed the momentum of
the game so selfishly I take a lot of
blame on that game um whether it was
right or wrong they called it and I I
got to try to be better as a teammate
and not count uh lose points for my team
so you know that bothers me a lot um and
then obviously my brother um to my
Cowboys fan that went viral because he
didn't want to come out his room at the
loss um it can always get better before
it get worse you know um I'mma die
trying for it to get better before it
could get worse um just the type of
competitor that's in me um that that
hurts my that hurts my soul is to lose I
hate to lose um you know thiss me more
than right here open the door it's right
[Laughter]
here you know that it bothers me anymore
bro I go out there every week and try to
give my all and you know uh it's gonna
get better I promise you know and that's
something I hold accountable on a
positive note I hope everyone had a
great Merry Christmas I hope everyone
got their present they wanted from Santa
um I hope y'all got y h y y Spirit up y
praise up I hope everything was great um
it's gonna be a good show today and I
can't wait to uh get into it um one team
I end up getting my teammate some shoes
um a nice jacket and and just kept it
simple and uh the best gift that I got
from a teammate um he gave me a $1,200
Amazon card and to me you know the
Amazon card you could use it for
anything and that was just a great gift
because I use I'm one of them people
that use Amazon all the time I'm
probably on Amazon almost every day
looking at stuff I buy from Amazon so
frequently like that was one of the best
gifts someone could give me um people
were hating on that gift but that was
like you could get do whatever you want
with Amazon and Amazon those you know
Amazon's like the best like simple um
but let's get right into it I think this
is gonna be a good episode let's get
into the MVP debate after the ra Ravens
win over the 49ers there's been a lot of
talk on social made about MVP being
Lamar's to lose obviously great win by
uh Baltimore I thought you know they
played a tord game against the 49ers who
most think is the best team in National
Football League and I still think they
are the best team in the National
Football League that is the 49ers um
obviously uh there was a lot of and
let's get into this before we do that um
and what defines the MVP candidate is it
individual stats team wins like what is
it you know it everyone blares like I
don't think it's fair to say that you
know Brock P's out of the conversation
off one bad game Lamar had bad games
Patrick Mahomes had bad games because
it's late in the season Bad Games happen
right I it just you know Dak had bad
games before like it's just not fair
just because it happened later if if you
look at how pinned out right when we
went down to play the 49ers Dak had four
well it might have been three
interceptions but we had four turnovers
right um now you know D was balling out
playing consistently great obviously we
had a couple losses and now they're
saying he's out of an MVP pery was
playing very good consistently
consistently and then he has a bloop and
then you know some of them could have
said you know they weren't his fault and
we'll get into a little bit later but
now he's out of the MVP conversation and
obviously Lamar hasn't played overly
amazing this year but he's been playing
winning football great football Lamar's
been balling obviously a top five
quarterback in the league and he was on
my top five debate from the beginning I
thought Lamar was playing great football
but there hasn't been a defining moment
of what is what makes someone the most
valuable player and you know to me the
way that the uh the Ravens
won I felt like the defense did more
than the offense and they could have
beat the breaks off the 49ers if the
49ers weren't so good right the 49ers
beat is 42 to10 um we had four turnovers
but look at that margin versus the score
was 33
to9 and this what I say some people not
they just hear what people are saying
but they don't actually love the game
they're not actually seeing what's going
on how many points off of turnovers did
the Niners hold uh to them to just three
you know obviously they had a couple
great drives and a couple scoring drives
but the fact that the score was 33 to 19
team with five turnovers is truly
incredible um it's something to really
look at um and obviously the Ravens
defense has been MVP they have a chance
to be number one in scoring number one
in sacks number one in takeaways and
that's so hard to do um and I just don't
think that it it like I think this year
doesn't have to be a quarterback right
if you're not going off stats and wins
um and you're looking at Raven schedule
the 4 9ers is obviously the best win but
they split with the Browns they split
with the Steelers um you know they they
lost to the Colt so there's not too many
like great over the-top wins that you
have to force it to a a quarterback I
think it could be a split Chris mcaffry
been has has over 20 touchdowns almost
2,000 yards and a total yards and it's
not even end of the season I mean this
can be a completely different you know
um obviously and then cuz is obviously
they're trying to compare it to wins and
how person's playing and winning
football and obviously Lamar stats
aren't overly top but he's still playing
winning football great football
obviously the best record in the uh AFC
but that defense to me stepped up to the
plate and won that game I and that's why
I always say defense will win
championships and I like I said I don't
think perie played overly bad right um
but that defense just made extraordinary
plays Kyle Hamilton made extraordinary
plays
um and that's it I mean let's look at
the stats between Dak and Lamar you know
and Dak doesn't even have the best stats
in the like P still up there for best
stats uh you know there there's a bunch
of players that can be up there for if
it's about stats right if we're looking
at Stats a bunch of players can be up
there right um but they're saying this
because obviously they're top of the AFC
and obviously they're winning but their
defense is playing extremely well Lamar
is a great playmaker he makes things out
of nothing made amazing throws he played
like an MVP last night but what is the
what are we labeling the terms of MVP
right um and this is the conversation
that people want to have and then let's
get into pie I don't think perie played
bad and people were looking at my tweet
um and they were they had all these
opinions but not once did I talk about
perie I talked about the things that was
going on in the game right and no I'm
not worried about the the 49ers I mean
everyone that I know and probably your
moms and your fathers were watching the
game on Christmas night too I'm telling
with my family watching the game I'm
driving down my thoughts am I worried
about the 49ers when I wake up
absolutely not I have two children I'm
not worried about the 49ers at all and
that's for Debo and whoever else I'm
talking about the game that's my fair
opinion from my page I I don't care
what's going over there they have great
players we have great players a bunch of
players in the league have great players
but I don't think he's bad like I said
you look at the fast action two three
tip balls obviously interceptions the
one to kyl Hamilton I know he wish he
could have back but I don't think he
played a bad game I just acknowledged
that there was deficiencies and what a
lot of people were not seeing right I
said they were down 21 we talked about
perie being down um playing from behind
can he play from behind can he have that
mvp moment where he shows us that it's
not a scheme and he is that
guy people fail to realize coaching
matters right and I think the 49ers do a
great job schematically of I think K
Shanahan is obviously one of the best
offensive coordinators um coaches in the
NFL right and they did a great job
schematically covering up weaknesses in
their team and I you look at and I'm not
saying P's a weakness at all before we
even get to that but you look at when
they drop back you seen guys like jvon
clowning getting after you seen when
Trent Williams went down is there more
besides that right schematically
everything's quick they obviously didn't
want to get into the dropback game
because what there was a lot of pressure
there's a lot of things that could come
up when you get into that game the 49ers
are a front runner they can play from be
they play they like to play from ahead
because obviously their defense is so
good that's all I was saying there's
nothing wrong with the truth people want
to say whatever about the truth um like
I said I think think P still having a
great year I have nothing against pie um
what people are trying to perceive or
whatever take from that message is not
about him it's about scheme scheme
matters uh players matter coaching
matters everything matters when you're
talking about the game of football no
player can just go out there and just
play whatever he wants and do whatever
he wants that's just not how it works
that's how touchdowns happens that's how
you know plays are made plays are made
through scheme and things like that
um but
you know it it happens bro everyone has
games not every interception is your
fault right we look at Mahomes
interceptions how many interceptions
were actually mahom faults not from drop
passes or things that went through his
receiver hands that went into the
defense it it happens it's just a
reality of the sport things aren't going
to be perfect things aren't going to go
the way we want them to go and that's
just the nature of the game it's
adversity the things they do the way p
is going to have to bounce back he's
just going to do what he does and put
the noise to the hush right nothing none
of this other stuff matters bro um but
that's just my take on a pretty
situation I never say he had a bad game
I just made notice of a simple point and
you know it's a point where they're
trying to get it to their guys and they
just make plays bro I mean look at the
hit that Marlon had on Debo that man
just makes plays he know how to make
people miss and there's nothing wrong
with that I think people always think it
always has to be the strength of the
quarterback that's why we always have to
give it to MVP to the quarterback
because the quarterback has to be the
best player he has to be the most
valuable player and reality it doesn't
always have to be the quarterback
Christian mcaffrey is the best player on
that team he's been the best player on W
teams even when Ken won the MVP look at
Christian mcaffry stats like come on
when they played together they were
magic they were butter obviously cam
knew that Christian knows that Christian
he's balling this year bro I mean it's
the truth people want to cry and
complain about the truth and it's just a
reality except what it is Christian m
he's a beast he's a horse he does it all
he's a receiver he's a running back he
runs hard he makes people Miss he has
great vision I mean he's a it is what it
is that's the truth bro like Christian
mcaffrey is that guy and I don't want
y'all to like like and Debo Samuel I act
like he's a monster look at George KD
stats he's leading almost every stat for
a tight end Debo samel he made the most
missed tackles in the NFL like you don't
like so when we say MVP it doesn't
always have to be a quarterback there is
so many players
that is the best on the team or the best
in the NFL right I mean let's just be re
let's have a reality check let's just be
realistic it doesn't matter what anyone
says it doesn't always have to be a
quarterback and we don't have to give it
to a quarterback this year right and and
that's just the truth and then we'll get
into the drama in Denver right we got
Russell Wilson obviously people would
say are we
surprised I mean obviously I'm not I'm
surprised that they decided to make this
action now um but what it's it's kind of
crazy because obvious we've been seeing
with Derek Carr um women doing all this
stuff like um obviously it didn't go the
way that people playing it right um as
pre-march 177 release Russell Wilson uh
have $85 million of dead cap uh 3 39
million cash in 2024 um if he passes
physical in March whatever whatever
um I know you guys probably all know
this um they don't want Russell Wier to
get injured or anything um obviously
this means he's probably gonna get
released what does this mean and
obviously we're saying it with Jimmy
gico Derek Carr I mean Matt Ryan before
I mean but what does this mean though
right I think and it's not Russ's fault
because he's still playing a great game
but when you're Denver right and you're
like okay you gotta think when they had
Tim Patrick cour Sun this is before all
the injuries they're like we have all
these weapons we got the running back
javante Williams was good um the defense
was obviously always been great in
Denver we need a quarterback that's
going to take us over the top win big
games and um send us to the Super Bowl
now Russell Wilson is playing good
football if if we could pull up his
stats um and compare him to anybody else
even Lamar or anybody else he is playing
great football but people don't want to
hear about a guy playing great football
and that's the reality like this is the
business all jokes aside people want to
win those big games you need to get us
over the hump so they're basically
saying this you know just like how they
got rid of Von Miller you know they got
rid of Randy Gregory um they got rid of
a bunch of other guys on their team
they're in rebuild mode I mean Russell
Wilson has three over 3,000 yards 26 TDS
eight interceptions he's still playing
great football but they're in rebuild
mode they're basically saying we don't
want to pay you all this money anymore
we can find a guy to come do this and
we're gonna use this money to build
again draft Capital get other players
and have a re fresh
start and that and that's just the
nature of the business I I mean we're
seeing it more and more um that's why I
think contract structuring and wording
is so important um the importance of a
good Agent so these type of things can't
happen or won't happen um and and and
that's just reality you know they're
always going to look out for the best
insance of their team and who's running
it you know and and and it's messed up
but um you know I think they feel like
Russell Wilson can't take him to that
Super Bowl they feel like he can't be
that Super Bowl caliber quarterback that
they thought he was or could be and I
think Russell could be I don't think I'm
not putting that narrative on him I
think he's played great football he's
done a lot of great throws made a lot of
big plays for them um but obviously they
feel otherwise and they're they're
trying to go into a different direction
um even Gino what Gino Gino said this
after tweeted this he said free three
and in reality um Westman playing as a
top quarterback this league and and this
is a bad situation um obviously not
feeling wanted by organization um when
you kind of you come into organization
and you got so many high hopes and you
got so many plans that you want to take
on organization and it doesn't take you
there obviously it sucks and uh you know
I think I think it' be great for rest to
be have a fresh start you know I think
Atlanta New Orleans um maybe New York I
think the state may be coming to that
direction um but I think Russ will be on
a prove a year next year I think he's
going to have a chance to prove himself
and do what he does best and I think
he's going to have to make plays and
show people why they made a mistake um
and things like that and another story
out this week is Jer getting suspended
for one Dame for conduct detrimental to
the team um basically he pulled himself
captain for the coin toss before the
game against Carolina um and let's hear
Jer explain his situ uh
decision
were you supposed to be a captain cuz
the team announces the three game
captains and you were the fourth and you
called a toss what happened there
oh yeah I mean you know it's only suting
you know I don't think coach knew I was
from Charlotte you know so so you just
did that on your own I mean I mean you
know I mean it was like a you know the
guys backed me up you know so they they
knew I was from here did you realize you
almost made a big mistake on the call
though what did I do well you said we
want to go on defense yeah which in
theory could they could have said then
you're electing to kick to to uh kick
off which you would lost the opportunity
then to receive in the second half yeah
no I told him that uh I said uh I want I
want our defense to be out there and
they all looked at me like I was crazy
I'm like I mean it's pretty simple what
I say like I want the defense to be they
like you mean defer I'm like yeah I
guess okay did he did he say that to you
the the mic was on we heard you really
no he was just like defer I was like
yeah everybody was like yeah everybody
was laughing I'm like what y'all
laughing at like it's pretty obvious
what I'm asking so did anyone say
anything to you when you got back to the
sideline why would
they the way I look at it Jer has been a
leader of this team he's been a
franchise obviously he's a franchise
player for the Green Bay Packers uh it's
almost as if I think he should have been
a captain obviously from Charlotte uh
the coaches have that research they that
knowledge and they could appointed him
uh Captain if they wanted to they just
chose not to make that decision and he
made it for himself uh you know the main
message that I heard from that and he
said the guys had his back you know
obviously if there was an agreement or
whatever in the locker room where they
felt like it was okay for him to do that
they it didn't matter and they felt like
they could have uh went out there I
think that's it was okay um if that
wasn't the agreement then obviously uh
there should be some other discussion
obviously the coaches or the head UPS uh
felt some type of way about it but it it
kind of is what it is you know um the
internet is going crazy over this and I
I have no idea why I think uh he's a man
that just wanted to be a captain and
show his family why he was one of the
best players for that franchise and uh
the work he's put in his show I mean
this is a All Pro uh Pro Bowl
quarterback and he's gave it all the
Green Bay um so I think at least they
could have done was made him capping um
I think they could have finded him uh
especially they're playing the Vikings
this week uh this is a big game with
Justin Jefferson out there you hate to
be in that image like oh we lost because
we didn't have our best corner or this
type of situation and you kind of know
where it goes with that uh jaer was
selfish and things like that uh that's
the type of image that people will
portray um because of this I felt like
they could have find them I felt like
the suspension may have been a little
bit over the top um a nice f
um something he can afford or whatever
uh could have done enough you know I
think um it might have been over top and
especially how the Vikings they threw
for over 400 they got some great weapons
over there obviously with Justin
Jefferson um I don't know how Addison's
feeling I think he went down last game
but I'm not too sure about that but I
think this may have went over the top uh
but you know obviously the Packers are
better with Jer out there um and this is
a sad situation for someone getting
suspended um for for that type incident
you know uh I could think of a million
other reasons why someone might get
suspended maybe something off the field
or uh something um completely uh vow and
things like that but this is a guy in
his eyes was just a guy like man I just
want to be a captain in my city and uh
and have a good good game and win and
and they did win so you know this is a
tough decision to see but uh towards the
end of the episode let's take some final
questions um from the chat I want to
hear from y'all um
and let's get into it if Dak gets an
extension this off season will he get
close to shotani money type money um I
don't know if the Market's like that I
think Dak has a chance to hit up to like
270 260 um between that 55 million in
that 60 uh million range I don't know
how long of extension he's going to get
I don't know um what type of agreement
they are in um but I'm pretty sure um my
guy Dak every dinner I go to is going to
be on him uh it's Joe Flaco leite I mean
obviously Joe Flaco's always been a
great player uh he's a Super Bowl
winning quarterback um and he's been in
league for a long time he's made some
great plays been an elite for a while um
you know so I think uh it's very
exciting um uh what he's doing and I
think he has a chance to be comeback
player of the year are we witnessing the
beginning of Patrick Mahomes downfall
that was a tough loss to the Raiders uh
I don't think so you you I look at it as
this is a team uh that's just going
going through the motions I mean
everyone goes through it uh but Patrick
Mahomes he's an MVP he's a he's a
two-time Super Bowl champ uh Super Bowl
MVP this is not his downfall um you know
it's always going to be some rain before
it gets sunny and I think right now it's
just it's being a little rainy and uh
it's raining right now in uh Kansas City
uh but you know they got great leaders
over there with Patrick Travis uh Chris
Jones the jerius sne vet guys uh Nick
Bolton they have a great unit over there
I think they can turn this around um
obviously Patrick Mahomes still playing
at a really good level I think it's just
a lot of frustration a lot of things
going on right now but it's going clear
right through should the Raiders remove
inum um from Antonio's Pierce title uh
for sure I think he should be the head
coach the way this team's locked in and
Bal in since he took over um I wouldn't
be surprised if there's a deal done
before the end of the season or right
after the season ends I mean the way the
way he's done and performed as a head
coach been amazing teams buying in
they're smoking cigars it just seems
like they got the love the passion for
football over there right now and it's
always good when the Raiders is a really
good team as Tommy DeVito Cinderella
store over um not necessarily you never
know what could happen with Tyrod uh
injuries happen but Tommy DeVito um
we've been seeing that as Josh dos and
Tommy DeVito and other players you know
and you know Jake Browning they go on
these tears and uh they feel like they
could go in other directions we'll see
what happens but Tommy was playing
really good football got some really big
wins so it' be interesting to see who's
getting picked number one in this draft
um obviously it' be Caleb Williams but I
don't know if it's going to be about the
Bears I do not agree that the Bears
should take him I think Justin Fields
put his team in positions to win a lot
of games they just didn't finish I think
another year with Justin our quarterback
could go a really really far I think
he's been really really great um and I
hope to see him in the Bears uniform I
think a team might trade up uh to go get
Caleb Williams though are you going to
play off ball this week uh it's not my
job to come in here and tell y'all game
plans uh this my job to try to give
y'all news and thoughts around the
league and and just keep it real simple
um and that's it you know I'm not trying
to get out here and you know give away
what I'm going be doing this week and
things like that uh Lions question
should Dan Campbell be win coach of the
year for sure the Lions haven't won a
division and uh over 30 years crazy stat
I mean the lions are looking good
they're locked in as a top seed and the
playoffs um and you know the lons just
just truly the way he turned that
organization around the way he got them
players to buy in um it is truly amazing
I'm super excited for the game um it's
going to be so fun uh playing against
Dan again we played him last year at
home uh really close game really fun um
and but Dan I mean he's just been a
great coach I mean it's truly amazing
what he's doing over there um and so
excited to play them um and you know it
it's really exciting to see what the uh
Detroit does in playoffs also obviously
being locked um but you know this is the
last episode before the new year so I
want to hear from y'all um y New Year's
resolutions um do y'all believe in that
um you know I'm not someone that
believes in Fresh Starts you know I
believe every day is a fresh start every
day you get an opportunity to change
your narrative you don't need a new year
or a new week to uh believe in that I
believe uh that's a beautiful thing
about life and the thing that I don't
believe a lot of people cherish enough
uh God is amazing you know God gave me
uh today to open my eyes close my eyes
hug my daughter hug my family and just
um you know really appreciate life that
daily blessing so I don't need uh a new
year that God bless us with the change
that you know I got every day to go out
there and uh you know the the most
amazing blessing you get every day is to
open your eyes and not everyone gets
that so you know I don't never believe
that I believe every day I get to open
my eyes I get to change my narrative I
get to change what people believe um and
how great I'm uh how great I can be
today and you know the the difference
between those are are great you know
they got to figure it out and those who
don't got it figured out they make
excuses why they don't got it figured
out and uh you know I'm just extremely
blessed and I hope everyone out there is
blessed too and I hope youall have a
blessed uh new year and if you are a
person that's waiting for that next
opportunity or that next year to say
this is going to be my year make every
day your year make every day your
opportunity to go out there shine glow
uh be amazing uh cast uh you know all
your love and energy upon others who
need it um go work for your fruits your
labors um because the perspective is is
that you don't need that you know you
got this every day you got this amazing
opportunity um that God still bless you
here you wouldn't be here for if it
wasn't for God and you you have a reason
to be here and it's something special so
keep uh striving for that every day and
I believe you got that and you know
that's it I appreciate everyone for
coming in uh tuning in to the edge you
know believe how much I believe your
support and I can't wait to see y'all
soon see y'all next
[Music]
week